this is Startalk hello and welcome
everyone to Startalk all-stars i'm your
all-star host of the evening Carolyn
Porco I'm a planetary scientist which
means I love planets I'm the leader of
the imaging science team on the Cassini
mission presently in orbit around Saturn
and a veteran imaging scientist of that
fabled mission Voyager 2 the outer solar
system in the 1980s
joining me is my comedic co-host is
Startalk veteran the very funny chuck
nice that remains to be seen thanks for
being here today thanks for being here
today Chuck last time we did this you
were such a champ you came here and did
two shows and you had a cold and the flu
I had the flu and you you're okay
yeah you know what I'm not contagious so
we're much better position okay because
today we have a very special guest with
us and that is Sean Ono Lennon welcome
Sean hello how do you do you are here
thanks for having me I made it you made
it in the humidity as I like to say if
you were alive and alert during the
1960s and it would be forgivable if you
weren't either you will certainly
recognize Sean's last two names yes he
is the son of John Lennon and Yoko Ono
and I know what you're all thinking but
that is not why I invited him here today
he is of course a musician and has been
for decades right that's correct
he's just completed a tour with his new
band called the Claypool Lennon delirium
which is fronted by both Sean and Les
Claypool most people will know less as
the lead guy in
Primus - yeah Ferg - on Wikipedia I'm
sorry I had to do this as a funk metal
band is that an accurate description you
know it's good enough for now okay wait
around 10 minutes of the change but
actually none of that is why Sean is
here today's here because I noticed as I
followed him on Twitter that he's a
serious
I called him badass signs groupie he
pays attention to what's going on in all
sorts of arenas like planetary
exploration and cosmology artificial
intelligence
technology the search for
extraterrestrial intelligence and on it
goes he even wears glasses that makes
him official and there's no prescription
and I found I found he was enamored with
Saturn which was cool by me and in fact
when he was a teenager he painted a
painting of Saturn that he recently sent
me which I think was adorable and
through all of this in the last few
months and lots of email exchanges and
discussions I found him to have a really
incisive intelligence a gentle soul and
he's a staunch feminist to boot so I
thought he'd be perfect to have on
Startalk
thanks anyway delight to have you I'm
really excited to be here ok ok so
there's so much we could talk about but
I wanted to begin with this since you
are a science groupie what is it about
science that draws you to it you didn't
become a scientist although you told me
you spent some time at Columbia you
actually went through three semesters at
Columbia I was at one point I was
interested in anthropology at Columbia
but then I kind of got distracted by a
record deal and all this and I'm not
sure if I regret it but I just left and
went to do music and I've been doing
that ever since I had a similar
experience where I went to Columbia and
they said listen you can't just be on
campus you actually have to go here and
then I had to leave yeah what do you
mean yeah actually you have to go attend
classes they said oh gee you didn't know
that was part of the contract that's
like what a cool campus okay why didn't
I go into science well yeah because you
think when I was young I was in a
boarding school it was kind of a strict
British boarding school and you know
they were pretty you know they
discouraged people who were you know
hippy you know children like me so I
don't know I felt maybe that I didn't
have the mathematic aptitude for some
later couraged people who were hippy -
yeah I think so I mean there was sort of
why are we talking well you know when I
was but I guess between 12 and 15 so you
are like this was the late 80s yeah but
I still don't know if I have the
aptitude for a real scientific work or
at least not the diligence but I
certainly a fan definitely RFU I can
tell you're a fan you know you think
deeply you wonder about the state of the
world like many of us do the future of
humanity from where you sit yeah hey on
Twitter everywhere whatever wherever you
look what do you think are the biggest
issues
yeah well I'm you know I think I think
we've all been really concerned recently
and I mean you know everyone that I know
at least with the state of the world
I mean politically and you know
environmentally and I remember growing
up and you've mentioned this before the
movie 2001 it seemed like we might at
least be you know taking trips to the
moon and living in some sort of you
Tawfik you know futuristic society when
I was young there was a kind of optimism
about the future and I've noticed in the
last 10 years that that kind of inherent
optimism has kind of been replaced by a
real pessimism and negativity about you
know the potential for humans to survive
at all so you know and I and I think
that it's concerning because you know
people tell me oh well you know there's
always been people worried about
Armageddon and throughout any period of
history but it's it's the first time
I've noticed that people that scientists
sort of unanimously talk about the
Anthropocene and the human caused
extinction epoch as something we just
sort of have to accept which is Nessun
means that we're bringing about our own
demise and you know learning to live in
today's world means accepting that
demise as a given well I don't I don't
know that I'm hearing scientists say
this but it's interesting that you think
you're hearing them say that we have to
accept it I think the role that
scientists are playing is to illuminate
the facts that know of course I agree
with you but the term Anthropocene means
human caused extinction epoch and so
that's real which essentially is it is
it is it doesn't mean that that's a
foregone conclusion or does it mean that
we have that potential because I think
the Anthropocene age that we live in is
shows that we are in we're on the
precipice that we can definitely bring
about our own demise but
that it's up to us whether or not that
happens I don't mean I don't think it
means the term means that we are gonna
bring about our own demise the way it it
just means that we are in a period of
geological history now where humans are
a mobile of misete right a major effect
it's not you know when you say Caroline
bet all of those effects are pretty bad
and that's why the assumption is we're
gonna bring about our own demise
well so aren't the epochs distinguished
by extinctions are not all of them I
don't think the boundaries are all that
way no I think like one species becomes
more dominant after that isn't that true
I forget I may be you know more about
this than I do but I am my regular
comedian please develop I'm not saying
that everyone agrees about what and the
Anthropocene is I just mean that I'm
hearing more and more legitimized
scientists say that you know well you
know it's not gonna make it you know why
because we are facing absolutely out of
control unprecedented problems right
yeah no it's one thing to be depressed
that you're not gonna you know have the
job you want by the time you die or you
know any number of things we all get
depressed about but when you start being
depressed as I am and I think there's a
word for it I'm sorry I don't know when
you're actually depressed about the
state of the world and not about you
know you love roses yeah and it's not a
neuroses I mean to think that you know I
thought like 2001 was horrible because
you just wouldn't think of building like
that with just buildings would have
planes flying into them and they would
go away live in New York right yeah I
was skyline changed like that yeah
suddenly things are not immutable sure
but in my mother's generation that
happened to Tokyo and I mean so it's
arguable that that the world has you
know always had challenges through every
generation but the question is is there
something distinctly different now and I
think yes it's environmental change that
is is going to bring about all sorts of
bad things absolutely
geopolitical instability exactly but
I've heard a lot of people say that it's
not the environmental change is going to
be nothing compared to just simply
making most jobs obsolete through
automation and robots and that's a
that's a very interesting point because
when you look at the future of just the
global workforce there are a lot of
people now calling for just universal
pay you know where you you know you just
pay people to be so that as a means of
getting rid of poverty because we're
gonna have a huge increase in the amount
of poverty go over the globally because
of the automation it's hard to
anticipate what's gonna happen but even
when I go to the airport now and they
force you to use the robotic kiosk I
remember the woman was like you gotta go
use it she was kind of rude to me and I
was like well wouldn't you prefer you
helped me because you know these robots
are displacing hundreds of deployed in
Europe you know any one of them lady why
are you so happy about you know
promoting the use of us that are
replacing you and she didn't even know
what I was talking about but do you find
it ironic you know that these kinds of
these kinds of automation are being sort
of you know forced upon us when we do
have a choice we can still employ people
to you know work at the airport but um
you know so I think that's just the
beginning of it but who knows how many
jobs could be misplaced by automation
and and the potential for the division
between the rich and the poor is is so
great I mean we think it's bad now but
it could be much worse in a hundred
years so I mean that worries me almost
as much as the answer era there are a
lot of worrisome things maybe we should
go to cosmic queries and see what
they've gotten squeezed maybe they've
see what other what other dark tales
that we can glean from the internet I
will recommend that book by Roy Scranton
called learning to die in the
Anthropocene because ultimately he does
have a sort of Zen view of you know how
we have to be motivated to have families
and you know be ambitious and work and
be productive the you know in a sort of
Zen sense and just live in the moment
and be happy to you know exist despite
you know the potential for a meteorite
impact in a hundred years or something
you know so I do think it's a good book
did make me a little nervous but I will
say that it's it's beautifully written
okay awesome
we'll note it well we have queries from
all over the internet whether it's
Facebook or Twitter or Instagram or you
name it
where people have written their
questions to you guys on all of these
things that we just talked about and
more so why don't we take our first one
which is from patreon a patreon patron
and for those of you who don't know if
you support us on patreon financially
we give you precedent basically you have
bribed us into reading one of your
questions and we don't mind we'll admit
that this is from Nick saza from ski ok
it's Nick I hope I got it right all
right fix Safranski says this with the
earth adding leap days to the calendar
every four years in Caroline this is
probably more you they already are we as
human beings moving our perception of
the seasons backwards or is the heart is
the hotter temperatures later in the
year due to climate change okay so
that's a non-sequitur okay thank you
because I thought maybe and listen Nick
that by no means am I going to disparage
your question but the two really aren't
related right pretty interesting though
it's making me think
yeah but I'm okay so yeah I don't even
know where to go with that okay leap
seconds being added is just a way to
bring about some kind of accounting of
time was the first one to do it in terms
of the calendars that you can memorize
which months have less than 31 days if
you start with January is f on a piano
keyboard and then the sharps f-sharp
g-sharp and a sharp are the are the less
than 31 day months and it actually
corresponds wearing all the 12 notes
correspond exactly to the numbers of
days in each month oh my god
oh that's weird I like it okay but
starting with that FEV is January yes F
would be January I am going to learn to
read music just so I can put that to
work in my life C would be dissin like
you know 30 days has September April
June and November
all the Lester to remember for me as a
musician because the piano keyboards a
man all right but it's interesting that
it corresponds I mean I think this is an
interesting segue to the intersection
between art and science because I mean
the diatonic scale was started by
Pythagoras you know I told you trouble
with this guy but it's interesting
because also there are seven days of the
week you know and Monday is Monday
Tuesday lining mouth you know nandi
mouthy Mars day is Tuesday neck Rudi is
Wednesday that's Mercury's Jupiter right
so they're named after the spheres and
as you know the diatonic scale was also
related to the music of the spheres
because in those days they believe that
the harmony of the ratios that they
found in the octaves which is you know
he plucked a string added a weight and
doubled it and then a third was actually
the ratios of fifths and and third that
are the diatonic scale and he thought
that correspond it directly well not
just Pythagoras but they all did to the
music of the spheres which was a sort of
planetary symphony that was the music of
God or something but I find that to be
interesting in that you find these same
ratios at least you know and Fibonacci
can be found in the music scale as well
are you talking about the golden mean
which I think oulous thing the Greeks
used the golden mean exactly so there
are these sort of mathematical
connections between music and and and
mass and you know I actually want this
morning I was trying to think about the
topic of you know what is the influence
of science on art and I was actually
trying to figure out well when did
actually when when actually was was the
separation of science and art because I
think early on I mean if you think about
you know Babylonians Egyptians even
Greeks art and science were totally
intertwined and I think it was probably
was that right yeah of course yeah of
course because mathematicians were
musicians and music was made by a
mathematician and you know the people
that built the pyramids were craftsmen I
would call them scientists because they
were Mason's they understood you know
astronomy and so what I mean is I think
even all the way up to the Renaissance
scientists were artists basically so I'm
just trying to wonder when did that
actually when did when did the
separation happen because I think
fundamentally it could have been when
I'm just going to take a guess it could
have been when scientists no longer were
supported by a benefactor you know you
could apply for grant money from the
government I was gonna say you only have
two minutes you know yeah man we really
did sorry to be the wet blanket so we
need to ask sorry we need to ask sorry
let's get to another question but that
was that was great fascinating well I
did want to tell you one quote you can
head this out but um
James Sylvester he was the Oxford
scientist who taught Florence
Nightingale who basically invented
modern nursing and he said that a music
is the mathematics of sense and mass is
the music of reason hold it say it again
music is the mathematics of sense sense
yes and mathematics is the music of
reason oh very nice yeah well I find
that to be true said that his name is
James Sylvester he was the Oxford
scientist who was the tutor for Florence
Nightingale who invented modern I love
this thing in the Victorian era
there's a beautiful reciprocity there
that works wonderfully I like that
alright we're we're almost out of time
so I'm one minute and one minutes I'm
going to get one that Carolyn that maybe
you can knock out for us in a minute
let's hope okay here we go Ronnie a
Morrison jr from facebook wants to know
this hey so Carolyn what in the world is
at Saturn's core could it be some kind
of dense liquid that's not molten or is
it just boring old rocky material thanks
a lot that's boring old rocky material
is it modern has a boring old rocky core
and then it's got a thick outer layer
where you go from atmosphere to
Oh God flu and I ionized hydrogen helium
and then you get into metallic hydrogen
and then you go into the core go into
the court yeah it's pretty nice hydrogen
just plasma yeah you too damn smart yeah
what point will they I don't understand
why you didn't become a scientist I got
wait a minute sighs stop right here we
have to take a short break we will be
back shortly and I need a break to
talking more science here on Startalk
all-stars welcome back to Startalk
all-stars
i am your host for today Carolyn Porco
and we have the always humorous Chuck
nice here today as well as our interests
our in-studio guests who regards himself
as less humorous but I don't science
groupie and musicians Sean Lennon so
thank you both for and we're finding out
that Sean is extremely science literate
like - well well inform inform inform
the coldness googling under the table so
we were we were talking about you know
the Anthropocene and all the awful
things that are happening climate change
and all the good stuff rave inequities
all the things that really are
concerning people today and and they
come with a bigger punch than usual
because they really seem like
catastrophic yeah like you know we're
we're on an exponential we're on an
exponential curve to the end so I had
this is something that Sean and I talked
about it over email and even when I went
to see you I went to see his show
Boston you come to this listen it was a
rockin show I hadn't been to a concert
and God knows how long my guitar I have
a picture of me with his sparkly green
guitar and I thought well for a moment
there I was infinitely cool Carolyn
Porco
rosco I don't believe in terms for that
so we're you so anyway we're thinking of
you know I think about how horrible our
stewardship of the planet has been how
we have behaved collectively with no
regard to animals and animal life as if
they are there for us or against us
depending on you know what we deem
important and even if we can find
optimism in technological achievements
and progress that comes from that I
wonder you know our fundamental nature
seems to be angel and devil together in
the same package and it seems to be to
our evolutionary advantage to kill or at
least regard with great suspicion
everything that is alien to us and to
protect our own will we ever be able to
get beyond this is anything on the
planet or earth really alien to us
though is that that's an interesting
well no in fact you know and I love when
I'm talking to people or on Twitter I
always love to regard talk about
anything we show on Twitter an animal a
bug you know anybody
it's another earthling right it's really
just let's reset the perception but this
is a serious question you know it's we
have both both are the reason why we
have become so successful right we kill
things that let our genetic material
advance into the future advance into the
future is that going to be the thing
that kills us where is and where can how
can we be optimistic where is there that
we can plant there examples there's so
many examples in nature of sustainable
systems though that's the thing so I
feel like we could easily benefit from
natural resources without destroying
them because there are a lot of examples
in nature where it's a symbiotic
relationship where you know well the
situation olivian our gut without them
we would die happy to give them ice
cream you know I mean so I feel like
it's possible to have a sustainable
Society but what I really want to ask
you is how do you feel about the
potential of I mean this is the kind of
stuff that I'm sure your audience likes
to hear about anyway I mean how do you
everyone's talking about colonizing Mars
like Elon Musk is talking about getting
there I mean if we can't even terraform
eras
ona what are the chances of us
terraforming a planet that has no
magnetic field
no continental drift I mean no
protection from you know the ocean the
radiation of the Sun and we can't even
you know terraform Arizona so I don't I
don't really see what if what the
realistic you know thinking is there
this is how I view this whole topic
first of all I'm a big fan of human
exploration that is as opposed to
robotic I'm a big fan of both I think
they go hand in hand there's a place for
both we're like close to human
exploration for you know the practical
reasons like it takes it would take a
human you know an instant to be walking
around on the surface of Mars and
identify a rock that was of interest it
would take a long time longer for a
robot to do it because the robots got to
be in touch with the ground and maybe
you could train them to recognize it but
you know we we've had you know billions
of years or yeah billions of years of
evolution to work off of to get to where
we are we're pretty good at that so
that's good but I also think human
exploration I'm digressing here is
important for the inspiration that it
allows people you know seeing someone do
something that is on the very edge of
what human is humanly possible mm-hmm
yeah but I don't think that for people
that people should be thinking we're
gonna take 7 billion people or 9 billion
people and move them to Mars that is not
going to happen we the the analog that I
think is applicable here is one where we
are going to set up the equivalent of
scientific research stations on
Antarctica we've had for decades now a
continuously inhabited research outpost
on Antarctica and valuable things are
done there and I think that's what we'll
do in the solar system but that's a much
more realistic view then but I've
learned a lot of you know books even
Michio Kaku when I was young I read a
book of his I was talking about this
Russian a scientist who has
qualifications for Phase one Society
Phase two Society and I think it was
your friend called Carl Sagan who
actually just made more
like a more smaller distinctions between
the phases but that essentially if you
survive a nuclear age then you get to
another phase of you know of a possible
extinction threat but then you can
eventually build a geodesic dome or
something or a Dyson Dyson your sphere
around the Sun and you get all this
energy and then you can make wormholes
and you can essentially populate the
universe I just feel like a lot of
people use that kind of theoretical
thinking to sort of justify the survival
or the the optimism that we might
survive as a species if we actually
populate the solar system or you know
elsewhere and I just feel like it's so
unrealistic because we as you said we're
not very good custodians of our own
planet so how could we possibly make a
place as in as hospitable as Mars ever
no the other the the antithesis of what
you're saying where the flip side more
than antithesis the flip side of that is
perhaps that's how we are here it is not
really about us populating other places
as in colonization but in ceding other
places the same way that we cede each
other to send our DNA into the future
that's why we have sex and we have minds
right we just I just want to impregnate
Mars is what I'm saying I'm gonna knock
you up Mars that's what's happening so
maybe it's not about colonization maybe
it's their survival you know the same
way on a cellular level we survive
because we send a single cell to a
single cell and then just saying this is
the expression of the base need exactly
it's an expression of a base need to to
survive that's a good question because I
just read an article that said if humans
will go extinct or we actually face the
extinction of life on the planet do we
have an obligation than to cede other
exoplanets with you know earthbound DNA
like should we send rockets and do our
own and throw pence per Mia Project to
spread life if we if we're looking at
our own extinction do we have a duty
to do that or is it bad to do that I
don't know about letting the prime
directive
these are moral questions but isn't it
just an incredibly fascinating question
to ponder
well you just like you could spend an
evening drinking a glass of wine in
front of a fireplace thinking about all
these things have a really good time
let's switch gears because you know you
guys kept bringing up Twitter so we have
some questions where people want to talk
about Twitter and we see who this person
is though kayvon or Kevon coot i think
these people are sending me fake names
just like them struggle i swear people
call me say on everyday okay so here's
what Kevon wants to know social media
has a representation for disseminating
false and misleading information but
since people are also being exposed to
the collective knowledge wisdom
education and expertise of other users
aren't they getting a more stimulating a
meaningful experience than they would
from just watching or reading news about
more traditional means
so is that collective knowledge that is
represented on a base like Twitter or
Facebook is that greater or is it more
harmful in that you could have more
people just believing wrong stuff well
here's you know it's the yin and yang of
everything but it's not older the older
I got I've gotten the more I realized
just about everything you can think of
has a good side and a bad side to me the
good side of Twitter is that first of
all you are accessing the knowledge of
lots of people that you wouldn't have
otherwise have access to you it's out
there sometimes I've sent things out on
Twitter and I realized oh my god that
site that's wrong I'm sorry I just hit
the send button three seconds later
someone's back and saying that's not
right you know I've got smart people
following me that's great it's also
great that it bypasses the the what's
the word here the
the guardians of the new that standard
the standard keepers gatekeepers I mean
are we finding the regular news media
are just it's all sensational it's
tabloid now it's tabloid they are doing
it for profits it's not doing it to
convey accurate information this whole
business of setting up a false
equivalence between someone who's
knowledgeable someone who doesn't know
jack right but just for the sake of
making it look like they're having a
reasonable discussion it looks like it's
an intellectual tennis match and it's
not so I like that about social media a
lot but the downside is that you're also
accessing people who have no self
control and they don't really know how
to engage in logical reasoned discussion
and they think the purpose of Twitter is
just to let it all hang out meaning
their anger you know even if it's mr.
rotten contemplating the ugliness of
Twitter you know a lot recently because
I'm I'm pretty active on Twitter and you
know I think at first my criticisms were
of the medium of Twitter and then I
started to realize that really it's more
of a cross section of people and it's my
issues have to do with with us with
people I think it's just people
expressing what they think and I think
normally we wouldn't be exposed to such
a cross-section of society but you know
Twitter is just us and what we see
depressing how many people don't i they
don't know how to engage they don't know
that you could criticize something
they've said and not criticize them they
take it personally and then and that's a
lack of critical thought right there
it's a lack of critical thought when
somebody makes a disagreement as a
personal attack you know and and so many
people do that on Twitter yeah but if so
many people just do that and that's you
know I really do think people need to be
trained they need to be trained in
critical thought they need to be trained
people need to be told how to vote I
don't even think people know how to have
no ad hominem no strawman arguments I
mean you know it's easy to I mean these
you know if you actually spend a little
time you can learn how to debate you
know with civility but I think again the
ugliness of Twitter is just the ugliness
of people and the beauty
Twitter is the beauty of people so but I
would say the biggest problem to me with
social media since that's you know the
topic is that I think a generation of
kids are learning how to represent
themselves through a 2-dimensional
Facebook page very well but they're not
learning how to represent themselves to
real physical human beings in a
relationship with them in a room and in
their lives and I think totally
different Shawn I totally disagree with
you different skills and you know in
fact you can get a very good job being a
master of social media these days you
know that's a skill in itself so do you
think that at some point in time in the
future that will actually have training
for people because when you think about
it we're still in the nascent stages of
social media it's not just in rhetoric
classes at any university you're gonna
learn about ad hominem attacks and all
that kind of stuff I mean it's been a
part of I think it needs to be almost
like vocational you do it you teach
people how to interact with other human
beings and I just don't think we're we
are given enough of that well cuz I
think he's out of fashion though that's
the thing when we were saying that you
know there's no empathy on Twitter it's
not it's not cool to be compassionate
I actually I won't to tell you it was
the pull it was the election season i
express compassion on some topic and the
woman I was having this fight or this
argument with referred to my response as
maudlin because I actually expressed
comply key you know you said something
nice should we take another question
because we're getting to the end of this
Islands a good vocabulary word though
kids all right here we go
let's go - who's Emma Larry from
Facebook yeah there was an easy one
right okay art has evolved through time
incorporating scientific advancements at
every step so maybe in the future is it
possible that animations or visual
effects that we see now may be
considered a form of primitive inspiring
art
oh of course oh yeah yeah that's kind of
like a no-brainer I think so
well I think they're more talking about
like the work that you do with your
visual imaging I don't do you look at
that as an art form as well oh I do I
think that was the one thing I did is
the leader of the imaging team you know
we all well I'll speak for myself I
didn't want to do what other people who
came before me had done it mm-hmm
you know with the images that we were
collecting I wanted to do something
different just to kind of add my mark
and I was always very disappointed oh we
have to go okay no seriously I was
always very disappointed with the way
for example not to criticize because the
Voyager project was like the best thing
that ever happened to me and I think
ever happened to anybody
but I just thought they didn't treat the
images as well as they should have they
didn't present them as beautifully as
they could have it was all get the
science out we're just making pictures
for the public because we got it we
could have a press conference coming up
and we have to do it I want I want this
to be the mechanism that takes the
public along for the ride so we paid
spent a lot of time I spent a lot of
time thinking about how to present the
pictures how to get the colors right and
so on portrait through the rings of
Saturn was such a beautiful classic my
mom is a big fan of that photo I know
and I would loved it Yoko Ono actually
complimented the day they are it smiled
like how cool is that that is amazing I
mean that's great that you thought you
bought artistic integrity to the science
thereby increasing the value of the
science is engaging the page and the
public that's fantastic well yeah thank
you I'm very proud of that so I guess we
are gonna have to take a short break but
don't go too far we'll be right back
here on Startalk Allstars hello and we
are back with Startalk Allstars I'm
Carolyn Porco your all-star host with
Chuck nice my comedic co-hosts right
thank you for being here Chuck and
joining us in person is musician and
total science groupie Sean Lennon yes we
had a Scooby hmm that's the most
important oh so where do we go from here
well one topic we haven't
disgust I feel honor bound and actually
interested to to get to this topic I
just caught you and les claypool in the
gang at the House of Blues in Boston
just a couple of weeks ago it was great
thank you I loved it I hadn't been to a
concert in a long time I forgot how
great at live music is it was wonderful
God always that great and he actually
dedicated a song to me I just felt so
old astronomy domine that Pink Floyd and
I got to take a picture with his sparkly
green guitar so I got a moment of like
feeling what a rock stars like the
lyrics are Jupiter and Saturn Oberon
Miranda and titania Wow well you know
what all those are you can tell me but
go there later so I want to know is
there something in particular that you
feel you like to convey with your music
you write your own and you know just go
there do you have plans to take it in a
different direction how is it evolved
over the years it's all about you as a
musician and you know yeah interesting I
mean and one thing I will ask I don't
want to dwell on this I promised we
wouldn't dwell on things like this but
do you feel almost is it like a calling
because of your heritage you know your
parents and so on you felt the calling
to be a musician did you feel almost
everyone's expecting me to that to do
that so that's what I'll do how did that
come about well I mean there were
several phases to it the truth is I was
playing music before I was conscious of
what a career was or even what the
public was I mean my introduction to the
public kind of came when my dad was
murdered because there was just crowds
of people out of that outside of the
house and they went suddenly oh my god
and they were singing if he's a chance
every day I mean it was for actually
years they'd always come back on the
anniversary and stuff so I think my
introduction to him being a public
person was through that and I remember
learning to play his songs on the piano
when I was very young very young as a
way of you know five so yeah kind of as
a way of feeling like I was you know
getting closer to him
especially after he'd passed away it was
a way of me sort of communing with him
or or getting a piece of him back
you know learning music by the time it
came to think about what is your career
I'd already kind of been doing music and
you know that's why I left school was to
to pursue music because they started
taking over my life so it was never
really a choice for me I was kind of
thrust into it for personal reasons but
you know I think the calling of so I was
gonna say it's a choice for any musician
what you just described I've heard so
many ditions describe the same thing my
brother is a musician and he went from
being a fund manager okay and doing that
for a while and then just going I can't
take it anymore I have to go do this
yeah you know what I mean and it's it's
that same thing where it's like you're
it's it's it's at first it feels like
it's thrust upon you but at the same
time you're you can't live without it
well yeah it wasn't until I was 19 or 20
that I started realizing there would be
a public reaction to whether I should or
shouldn't have played music in the first
place
and you know it's been a learning
process since then but I mean most of
what I've learned is that I just have to
kind of not think so much about what
people how people feel about me being
musician and just focus on you know the
work I imagine you have a very you have
the canonical burden of a child of a
very famous person right you're you're
always going to be compared that must be
like so painful and so irritating you're
so delightful okay you said that can I
tell you a little story sure can I tell
you a little story not good to embarrass
you but I'm walking to this studio right
because I'm staying only on 25th Street
I decided to walk in the heat and I
passed two young girls they look like
they're teenagers or 20 years old and I
hear them talking about you really
they're talking about you and one says
yeah yeah I kind of like Sean Lennon
yeah I think he's really cute oh that's
nice
two girls in all of America no I don't
think so anyway so so guys very cool
though yeah well listen speaking of that
let's get to a a cosmic query about kind
of like art and science and since you
kind of embody both and this one Chris
Emmett and he says how does art inspires
scientists to think outside of the box
and vice-versa
so for you how does art push your
boundaries your perspectives further out
and for you how this science push your
artistic boundaries is I know you did
what was it the monolith of the Phobos
right a monolith of Elvis's our record
title yeah so like I mean clearly
there's an association there for both of
you so yeah I mean for me fundamentally
music is mass I mean you know there's
basically XYZ axis of the time in which
the note is placed the pitch of the note
and then the the volume of that note I
mean Tambor could be arguably a fourth
axis but I mean it's very mathematical
it's easy to chart music on a graph and
so you know I think any musician who
stops to think about it would would
would really you know think of of melody
as a kind of audio geometry you know so
I mean it is math and most of the people
that I know who are very mathematically
minded are huge music nerds you know my
friend Eric Weinstein he's a famous
mathematician physicist economist you
know he all he ever wants to talk to me
about is like whether Robert Johnson is
cooler than Roy Harper well for me the
the umask you asked me this question I
know that I'll just say that I love
space art I love space art I love what
space art is do the scenes that they
create you know I meet them at NASA
don't you because often you have to
visualize illustrations that I noticed
when you I mean you can't take a picture
of an exoplanet but but NASA releases
these sort of Illustrated what if it you
know
a lot of we're sitting on you know Titan
or something right oh yes but I'm
talking about the genuine space artists
who just do it for a living and I'm so
I'm this is another one of those things
I did that you know I'm very happy I did
I didn't don't think anybody was doing
it before I did but on our Cyclops
website that we set up for the public
that is you know me and the Cassini
imaging team there's a special section
there that is devoted to space artists
you know just what the scenes they've
depicted of Saturn or we actually go
beyond Saturn but the Rings and Titan
and and I love looking at those and I
love looking at you know just what the
scenes on exoplanets because that's a
way to be there you know these people
painting you're friended of the rings of
Saturn the view of looking at those
irregularities that are like how high
are they oh the fabulous okay wonderful
that you brought that up yes we found in
the Rings we found this incredible thing
I mean the Rings are only thirty feet
thick okay that they're so why they're
bigger than the earth like much bigger
right I mean they would fit in from end
to end between the Earth and the moon
yeah I love and then we found on the
edge of the B ring and we also explained
a similar thing on the edge of a gap in
the outer a ring we found these
mountainous waves of rubble that extend
two and three miles high
is that the resonance with the moons
right yeah it's a little complicated in
one case that moon is nearby and it
actually because it's on an inclined
orbit it draws the particles out of the
plane not complicated it's just like
pushing a kid on a swing and every time
you push it and goes farther right okay
except that what's complicated is
because of that pushing on the swing the
orbits of the particles become eccentric
and that means in certain regions of the
orbit that gets squeezed together and
that has to push them higher right on
the outer edge of the B ring these
things of these rubble piles these
rubble mountains are very irregular
looking but they're high so imagine this
you've got a sheet of material that's 30
feet thick something coming out that's
miles high and ice I've often said in
public how fast I'm spending like forty
thousand miles an hour yeah right and so
so you say you'd like to take a craft
there
when they bet are you just being
hyperbolic cuz I mean that sounds like a
very dangerous place to drive it this is
just like all in my mind's eye
impossible to actually have a cello
craft that close to these spinning yes
three rings really yeah Sports to me you
could be over the Rings you know and if
you're really close to the Rings the
Rings would look like they extend to
infinity to you effectively solo and
imagine you're flying flying flying and
then you come across a wall of rubble
that's two or three miles high so I the
artist who did this I think had heard me
say that and he wanted to paint it so we
went back and forth as to what it should
look like and it's in a Chevy Nova
[Laughter]
connection between art and science I
think they're just they're - they're
just like two products of the humans so
in mind so lightning round she's a
perfect example of someone who could be
a scientist and an artist kind of at the
same time the confluence of engineering
and art in his brain was was it's not
only it's not only that it's I think
they derive the same wellspring you know
the same kind of deep soul that loves to
you know wants to make this is how it is
for me wants to make a connection with
the natural world I mean a deep like
almost High Priestess kind of connection
yeah science is the only way to do it
and music is I should say shouldn't say
the only but music is another right well
I think that's what music is beautiful
because you recognize harmonies which
are you know harmonic geometries that
are you know the same reason that
numbers describing the universe can have
their own Beauty to them and I think
it's exactly the same thing
absolutely all right speaking of
beauties let's get to the rest of our
questions we're gonna move to a
lightning round right now okay I hope
that's possible in the short period of
time remaining okay like I'm going here
we go let's make them do it here we go
this from Michael will Waja will toss
who says do you see how virtual reality
and augmented reality can influence art
and architecture do I see has it already
has with very ugly buildings in Germany
okay Bing there we go John Allen would
like to know this do you think that's
Media spreads more information
misinformation than information is a net
gain or loss for our understanding of
science it's impossible to measure come
on it's like either end not either/or I
was gonna say the same thing it's gonna
be a wash it's a watch there you go boom
let's move on to David Connelly David
Connolly from Facebook would like to
know this
the oceans are expanding so maybe we
should consider returning to the water
that'll take too long
so let's just stay landlubbers orphans
return to the water afternoon a pig-like
mammal will be there so let's go to
Steven B who comes to us from Twitter
who says this hi Carolyn what would be
the social and religious impacts of the
discovery of a more advanced alien
civilization oh my god
catastrophic it would it would confirm
all of religion world peace have to be
more more evolved than us I mean just it
just even equals or early ha but I just
like what do I think the person is
getting it to the issue like would we be
so freaked out we'd run for cover right
it would be great I hope I live to see
it this is a salad a Mian from Instagram
would like to know this do you think
that social medias are getting or making
people dumb all right here we go this
one is from Hubert or Oh I am NOT even
trying I'm not trying I'm sorry you bet
you Humberto go frost whatever he wants
to know this
do you consider cheating to use
technology to create arts this is for
both of you is technology cheating no is
it paintbrush cheating no I don't know
I'm passing its hardest technology
obviously there's no but I mean to do to
have no for human inspirational input
into it and like the deep dream bought
that
made all those weird surrealist of
google images I mean even dream bot was
programmed by peoples of them okay we
have yet to have art Pope created by now
we have to wrap it up we've got only 9
seconds left thank you all to all our
wonderful listeners for all those great
questions you can get more star talk by
following us on Twitter at star talk
radio Chuck where can the people get
more of you my living room I'll be there
this afternoon please come by come by no
no I'm on Twitter at chop nice comic and
that's where I interact with most people
ok and Shawn I know you are at at Shawn
Ono Lennon because that's where you and
I met up that's one of the really good
things about Twitter for me and you can
find me at Carolyn Porco all one word my
record companies can mirror music.com if
you're interested in music yeah and go
ccl2 look they can't see you anymore
right here yeah the Claypool Lennon
deliriums I'm Ben no I'm playing in
October and we're about to make another
record so yeah check us out no the
record great ok looking forward to that
so thank you chuck for co-hosting
tonight and to special guest Sean Lennon
for geeking out with us tonight even
though he doesn't think he kicked out I
am your host Carolyn Porco until next
time this is Startalk
[Music]